Can I get some money from the car mirror?
It's not a pity,
it stimulates
me [music] A little bit of ingredients, lightness
, and saltiness.
Yukihira
Iwaiba used the meat of the part of the bear that is close to its bones without fear.
And that tendency is even stronger in the case of gibier, which is full of wild flavor.
The strength of the smell is the latent power that is directly linked to the
sweetness of course
.  I thought this person was somewhat like a stage performer,
but it seems like a job Sealer
Future Shadows
[Music]
Yukihira Yes,
he mixed different parts of bear meat and minced them.
It makes you feel the multi-layered aviation. With
this dish, he walked a
tightrope.  You seem to have recognized a flat item.